[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
hola buenas tardes
me pregunto un poco yo por qué estoy acá
no me pregunte cuando me invitaron a la
charla porque aceptara venir
básicamente muchas gracias
básicamente porque gran parte de mi vida
dedique
mi tiempo digamos hacer investigaciones
sobre redes de datos sobre sistemas
sobre como bien decía chicos recién el
tema de hacking me interesa mucho la
segura informática me interesa mucho los
sistemas de un tiempo esta parte y me
interesaba como vulnerar esos sistemas
como afectar la integridad la seguridad
de esos sistemas pero también de un
tiempo esta parte me empezó a interesar
otro tipo de riesgos que afectan
básicamente a las personas yo no sé si
está este cambio vino de alguna manera
por por ser padre que me tocó ser padre
tengo dos hermosas hijas
también me tocó estar gracias a mi
trabajo en contacto con
con gente que ha padecido algunas cosas
a través de medios tecnológicos entonces
eso me empezó a hacer un poco de ruido
en la cabeza y ver cómo podía ayudar un
poco con todo eso
yo le hago una pregunta cuántos de
ustedes acá tienen cuenta de facebook
levanten la mano
era de esperarse cuantos tienen una
cuenta de instagram
era esperar sé cuánto tienen una cuenta
de snap chat
bueno cuánto tiene una cuenta de dice q
era de esperarse mira conocen esto
delata un poco miedo también
ahora le voy a preguntar lo siguiente si
yo le pregunto ustedes que prefieren
hacer
preferirían estar paseando por una plaza
oscura
totalmente a oscuras en silencio en un
lugar no céntrico o le digo preferiría
estar en sus casas tranquilos navegando
en internet con una tablet con una
computadora o con el teléfono celular yo
creo que la respuesta bastante obvia van
a estar quedar van a querer estar
tirados en su cama navegando revisando
sus redes sociales y demás y yo creo que
a sus padres también les va a gustar y
van a querer lo mismo ahora la noticia
que yo tengo es
tenemos que empezar a hacer un poco una
diferenciación
[Música]
y tratar de comprender que no son tan
distintas estos dos lugares es todo lo
que yo les digo yo casualmente he tenido
la oportunidad de hablar muchas veces
con padres y con gente adulta acerca del
comportamiento de sus hijos utilizando
las redes sociales y además por eso
cuando yo me preguntaba el por qué estoy
acá me pareció una muy buena oportunidad
de hablarles a ustedes directamente a
los actores de los temas que les voy a
mencionar ahora
ella es micaela ortega quizás la
recuerden fue noticia el año pasado
desapareció la estuvieron buscando casi
durante un mes
casualmente recientemente tuvimos un
caso de otra chica también llamado mi
carrera pero la particular de micaela
era es la siguiente ella tenía 12 años y
tenía como muchos de ustedes imagino
varios perfiles en facebook
digamos no no es algo real yo sé que es
así sé que muchas veces buscan escapar
de ciertos controles de sus padres o de
gente que estaba a su cargo
es una práctica que comúnmente ocurre
mi carrera tenía cuatro perfiles en
facebook concretamente
empezó a interactuar con una chica a
través de uno de esos de esos perfiles y
finalmente un día
establecieron una relación importante
con esta chica le contaba todo lo que
pasaba en su casa un día le cuenta que
tiene una pelea con su madre micaela
tiene una pelea con su madre como muchos
de nosotros tenemos pelea con nuestros
padres por supuesto
tuvo una reacción y quiso confiar en su
amiga entonces un día decidió irse con
su amiga finalmente no se encontró con
su amiga se encontró con jonathan luna
de 26 años que tenía una condena y
estaba fugado de la cárcel en riga tenía
salidas transitorias y en la primera no
volvió jonathan la tenía
76 años tiene 26 está preso actualmente
tenía también cuatro perfiles falsos ahí
abajo pueden ver un poco los nombres
tengo entendido que con el último fue
que el interact o con micaela
y tenía 1.700 mujeres menores de 13 años
en su mayoría no todas menores de 13
años entre entre sus contactos en los
perfiles que tenían
qué pasó mi carrera fue encontrarse con
su amiga se encontró con este muchacho
que dijo hacer el primo de su amiga la
llevó a un descampado como no pudo
violarla la mató estrangulándola con una
remera perdonen la crudeza pero es la
manera de que quiero que entiendan un
poco
el problema del cual estoy hablando
quizás este es un caso un poco más
extremo hay infinidad de situaciones que
se viven día a día en las redes sociales
vamos a tratar de separar un poco los
tantos esta declaración me parece
interesante que la vean
es la abogada de la familia micaela
comprendiendo un poco el marco de dolor
que toda la gente tenía en ese momento
pero finalmente la abogada hace esta
declaración no mi cadera fue víctima de
las redes sociales ustedes que piensan
que es así yo la verdad no pienso es así
mi cadera fue víctima de un asesino de
una persona que la mató las redes
sociales si bien facilitan las cosas
para las personas
quizás inescrupulosas que quieren hacer
cosas que bueno que ya sabemos cuáles
son los resultados
yo creo que no está bien echarle la
culpa a las tecnologías a las
tecnologías ya las redes sociales la
tecnología llegó para usarse está bien
que las usen pero está bien que la
usemos con cierta responsabilidad
yo creo que ustedes muchos de ustedes
han escuchado quizás estos términos
grooming lo que es la porno venganza lo
que es el sexting lo que es el ciber
bullying por supuesto yo creo que
ustedes
al menos lo han escuchado no sé si saben
bien de qué se trata lo podemos ir
viendo ahora
pero lo importante lo que quiero que
sepan es que
se conozcan los riesgos conozcan los
riesgos de cada una de estas prácticas
qué significa lo importante es saber de
estas cosas es tener en cuenta lo que es
el antes y el después que quiero decir
con esto
y ustedes conocen bien el término
viralización sabemos que cuando algo
sale de nuestro teléfono de nuestro
nuestro computador a lo que sea
por más conocimientos en informática que
uno tenga por más conocimiento de
hacking de más cosas es difícil de tener
una bola de nieve que se genera porque
ya uno pierde el control de la
información si uno
le manda a alguien una foto quizás
comprometedora para uno mismo y ya
perdió totalmente el control porque ya
depende de otras voluntades
hay diferencias no eran encomendárselo a
una persona que manolo un grupo de
whatsapp con 40 50 personas que la
mayoría quizá uno no conoce está claro
que tiene efectos diferentes pero ya el
hecho de enviarlo o de subirlo a alguna
plataforma
quiero que sepan que ya uno pierde el
control sobre eso
bien
[Música]
por eso siempre digo que siempre aplica
muy bien el término en el dicho popular
más vale prevenir que lamentar siempre
que podamos evitarlo tratemos de
evitarlo
me refiero a este tema de compartir
fotos comprometedoras comprometer
contenidos que por ahí después nos puede
jugar en contra lo que si no le voy a
decir es decir no no lo hagan por favor
no lo hagan no yo creo que estamos en
año 2017 de la tecnología hay que usarla
y si a ustedes les gusta sacarse fotos a
ustedes o con su pareja bueno todos
tienen derecho a la intimidad también no
no debemos afectar ese derecho de alguna
manera pero si lo que les pido es que
midan los riesgos le pido que midan las
consecuencias y traten de ver como el
poder a futuro no será afectados por
esas acciones
quería que vean también algunas noticias
que recopilen algunas pocas
para que vean que ambos son casos
comunes ocurren ocurren acá y ocurre en
esta ciudad no es que ocurren en
cualquier parte del mundo por supuesto
ocurre en todos lados pero es algo que
nos está afectando directamente a
nosotros acá
la mayoría obviamente son casos de la
ciudad de rosario ustedes pueden ver la
descripción de cada uno
no solamente estamos hablando de un
fenómeno importante como es el grooming
a ya sabe lo que es el grume acá levante
la mano por favor bien son pocos pensé
que iba a ser más grooming básicamente
es una acción deliberada a través de las
redes hacia los menores con fines
sexuales o sea la idea es engañar
a un menor así como para después obtener
otro
otro beneficio si se quiere para esta
persona
esas otras acciones que van a
continuación después del momento de la
extorsión que existe previamente del del
hostigamiento y el acoso puede decaer en
lo que viene es la pedofilia sí o caer
en una red de trata o directamente ya
otro delito peor como es un crimen como
le ocurrió a micaela
yo quiero que sepan también que deben
apoyarse donde en primer lugar en la
familia
yo sé que por ahí en una edad por ahí
que ustedes están puede ser un tanto
complicado establecer un diálogo con los
padres me ha pasado mi madre se va a
reír cuando vea el vídeo de esta charla
pero es así pero lamentablemente hoy por
hoy es el sustento y el apoyo principal
y el arma principal contra esto que está
ocurriendo
yo creo que la familia
no deben dejarla de lado jamás si
siempre sepan que nunca es tarde si
ustedes están bajo un problema de un
hostigamiento en la red si están alguien
nos está maltratando si acá ya pasamos a
hablar de lo que llama el ciber bullying
si alguien está haciendo cosas con fotos
de ustedes pasándola mal con alguna
situación que no les gusta siempre
traten de recurrir a las personas más
cercanas si desean no hacerlo y quieren
buscar apoyo en otro lado hay
organizaciones que están trabajando muy
fuerte con todos estos como son
argentinas y ver seguras y grooming
argentinas casualmente el grooming
argentina si ustedes entran a la página
tienen un número una línea abierta que
lo pueden consultar por whatsapp y hacer
una si se quiere una denuncia no llega a
ser una denuncia
de carácter penal pero si la pueden
tener un punto de inicio con esa gente
que lo va a ayudar esto en el caso de
que no quisieron hablar por ahí con sus
padres o demás
así que
bien
la idea es un poco entonces que conozcan
y que sepan medir los riesgos cuando
ustedes por ejemplo postean algo en el
internet si traten de ver que quieren
lograr con ese post cuál es el efecto
que quieren lograr y sobre todo piensen
qué efectos va a tener en otras personas
porque uno siempre piensa qué
porque yo entiendo a ver cómo funciona
esto de la popularidad casualmente lo
entendí hace muy poquito con mi sobrino
de 11 años que me dice tío qué lindo
teléfono pero también un poquito creo
que lo a ver bueno se lo desbloqueo se
lo muestro empieza a mirar las
aplicaciones pero con una seguridad que
no estaba mirando el teléfono busco la
aplicación instagram se buscó el agarra
una foto y le dio un like
claro entonces ahí comprendí que tener
más like que tener más lo que sea
digamos más vistas eso da un estatus en
un grupo
lo que sí quiero decirles que nuevamente
traten de ver que realmente lo que
queremos compartir y a costo de que yo
sé que por ahí las fotos sobre todo para
las chicas una foto para ir con menos
ropa y lo que sea les va a redituar más
más me gusta más más compartir lo demás
pero también la popularidad nos puede
llevar por caminos equivocados de qué
sirve tener un perfil con 500 amigos
amigos de facebook
cómo podemos medir cómo podemos unir la
sala cómo podemos controlar nuestra
audiencia si se quiere no saber quién
está detrás de esos 500 amigos nunca
sabemos nunca sabemos así que traten de
pensar un poco en eso por favor pero si
así ustedes lo decidieran y quisieran
seguir adelante yo les puedo brindar
algunos tips esto me parece que pasó
tenemos algunos tips como para que
ustedes puedan tener en cuenta si al
momento de estar un poco más seguro en
las redes revisen los ajustes de
privacidad todas las plataformas lo
tienen incluso cada vez más fáciles
están de algo que los va guiando y le va
diciendo que ajustar que no ajustar una
vez que usted tienen que leer un montón
de cosas simplemente tómense un ratito
sí y poner los ajustes de privacidad
como como ustedes más les guste y se
sientan más seguros no tienen por qué
mostrarle a todo el mundo todo lo que
ustedes están publicando
constantemente no publicamos yo también
lo hago no se crean que es algo que ya
está en nosotros
tómense un ratito para segur izar los
dispositivos
esto significa ponerle una clave yo
entiendo que la seguridad no va de
ninguna ninguna manera de la mano con la
comodidad a todos nos molesta poner una
contraseña y ni hablar si les digo que
encripten el teléfono o sea que los
cifran la memoria por ejemplo porque eso
también puede ayudar a evitar
estamos con problemático con la
presentación nos puede ayudar a evitar
también algunas fugas de información
estas fotos que se filtran sepan ustedes
que por más que tengan una clave en el
teléfono si le saca una memoria interna
la llevan un servicio técnico las llevan
a un amigo y demás ya saben las
consecuencias que puede tener
así que tomarse un trabajito también
para asegurar el dispositivo controlen
la cantidad de aplicaciones que van
instalando no hay razón para tener mil
aplicaciones aplicaciones que no hacen
nada pero que si les solicitan un montón
de permisos para ver la foto para
acceder a la cámara para acceder al
micrófono fíjense si es necesario
y utilizan también algunas aplicaciones
como le decía si toman la decisión de
hacerse fotos de compartir fotos
repito la privacidad de cada uno están
en su derecho de hacerlo también pueden
utilizar aplicaciones como para tener un
buen resguardo esas cosas ese material
hay aplicaciones para android para
iphone como por ejemplo el firewall creo
que se llamaba donde es una bóveda
justamente que se protege con una
contraseña y si no tenéis esa contraseña
no puedes acceder a las fotos por más
que tenga el teléfono sin sin claves
también pueden utilizar programas de
mensajería como telegram que permite
enviar un mensaje con sistema de
autodestrucción o sea yo puedo
asegurarme que vos lea el mensaje y se
autodestruya y me avisas si toma una
captura de pantalla también
y bueno después por supuesto utilizar el
sentido común
que muchas veces no es tan fácil y lo
que iniciaba medir los efectos de
nuestras acciones en internet saber qué
hacemos y que no hacemos yo creo que
ustedes lo van a entender mejor
sus padres quizás les cuesta un poco
transmitirle algunas cosas porque
sabemos que no tienen la facilidad que
tienen ustedes con la tecnología pero yo
creo que está en responsabilidad de cada
uno de nosotros de ustedes de ustedes
sobre todo para qué
internet no sea como dijimos del
principio una plaza oscura y peligrosa
bueno muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
no no no
[Música]